I was actually talking earlier about this mother
who doesn't want her daughter to dress
in black for her wedding.
Yeah.
And that I empathize with her
because my daughter wanted a death-themed birthday party.
Yeah.
And I was like,
"I can't scare the other parents."
And then the invitation is that.
And... (chuckles)
She's my girl, okay?
Wait.
(audience laughs)
I had a birthday party like that, too.
Okay, so tell me about this birthday party
'cause it sounds
(Patricia laughs)
like actually like maybe something we could all adapt.
I don't know.
(Patricia laughs)
It sounds so cool. What was it?
So when I turned 40, I had a wake for my youth.
Yeah!
So, yeah.
(audience applauds)
I had skull and crossbones.
And people were making eulogies that were silly,
and tongue in cheek, and funny.
And it was like, ah, let's bury that part of my life
and start anew.
(audience laughs)
I've never heard of anyone doing that.
And I feel like that is a trend
that could pick up steam.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was fun.
(audience applauds)
It was really, really fun.
Okay, well, I'm into that.
And it is your birthday actually right now, right?
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
April 8th.
Springtime, yup.
I wish for all of your wishes to come true.
Oh, thanks, honey.
Okay, so okay, I usually have this like in my head,
but because I wasn't prepared...
We were both rebellious teenagers.
Yes, that's true.
What's the craziest thing you ever did?
I can think of a lot.
I mean, there are a lot.
(audience laughs)
But crazy enough to talk about here?
Me and my friend got arrested shoplifting.
And so I went to the police station,
all that stuff, waited for them.
And then when I had to go back, the judge,
or I don't even know who this person was,
mediator or something, anyway, whoever he was,
he said, "Will you ever do this again?"
And I said, "No."
But he's like, "Okay, I believe you.
I'm gonna let you off on a warning."
And I said, "No, no, I think I should be punished.
I don't think I should just be let off like that."
And he was like, "Okay, okay. (laughs)
How about this for punishment?
You go to therapy until you think you're done."
And I was like, "Okay, that sounds good.
I'll go to therapy."
Was the therapy good?
Or was it like...
Well, I love therapy,
but I kept falling asleep in therapy.
(audience laughs)
Fall asleep on the set.
You fall asleep in therapy.
I know. (laughs)
I'm kind of a sleeper.
I love that you're like,
no, I would like the full extent-
Of the punishment, yeah.
Okay, you are obviously in "Severance,"
which is on Apple TV+ right now.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
And this just in hot off the wire,
it's been picked up for season two.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
That show is so avant-garde, cool, weird, interesting.
It's so wild.
Yeah, it's really a very interesting tone.
It's about this Lumon Industries,
and certain people that work there decide
to go through this procedure called severance
where they separate a part of their brain.
So their part of them that goes to work
doesn't remember their home life.
And the part of them that's at home
doesn't remember their work life.
And I play this upper management woman
who's sort of overseeing this department.
It just begs such a rich, wild, impossible,
but like, I don't know
what's impossible anymore in the world.
Everything-
Yeah.
Maybe is possible, and-
It is just such a ride
of a show.
Congratulations on it
getting picked up.
Thank you.
Don't ever get severed.
(audience applauds)
That's all I have to say.
No. (laughs)
We have a clip here, actually.
Will you please roll that for us?
(switch clicks)
Or were you sniffing around other departments
while your department falls woefully below quota?
She almost died.
It's not your job to play nurse made to every new refiner.
Okay. So what is my job?
Are you really asking me that?
Yeah.
What is it we actually do here?
We serve Kier, you child!
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
The entire season of "Severance" is available
on Apple TV+ right now.
Ah.
Oh, I love you so much.
(upbeat pop music)